ですから、単語の真ん中ではzaです
が、単語の最初ではza
です。私の日本の学校では、rが
英語と本質的に同じであると
言ってい
ます。 他の発音関連の
質問いいえいいえ私は今のところ良いと思います
が、あなたが望むなら、私たちは
声の演技のアドバイスを始めることができますええ
やり
ます大丈夫です
うまくいけば、私は失敗しないでしょう。
私のyoutube vidsでの4年半の演技の後、
私はバナナを買うために食料雑貨店に行ったという文を言います
が、彼らが持っていたのはトマトだけだったので、私は
怒っているか失望していますか？
今のところ心配しないでください最初に
文を
言ってみましょう ああ
しかし、今回
は少しイライラして行動してみてください。
同じ基本文が必要
です。これは、正しく処理されている場合は、より自然な
言い方ですが、これが機能するためには、
あなたが本当に仕事をしているようなら、あなたはそう言うかもしれませ
ん
が、私が適切に
評価し、強調
するために元の文に戻るために、バディ
は私がabマイナスを取得したと私に言わないでくださいあなた
はabマイナスを取得しませんでし
た ユーチューブで何年もこれをやってい
て、私はあなたが頑張っている私の音声学を知ってい
ます、そしてそれ
は実際にあなたの日本語の音を悪化させ
ます 10年以上
日本語学の学位を持っている
私はあなたの日本語の
発音が不自然
だと言っているのではない私はあなたの不自然な声の演技
があなたの日本語の音を少し
悪くしていると
言っている 誰がいい
あなたよりも日本語で演じる声で、またはあなたよりも日本語が
上手な人
ジェリー私は両方のジョーイが別の人に名前を付けることを意味します
それが自然に聞こえなかった理由だと思うようになった
ので、これは
どうですか？例文を選びます